in the video on the Cambrian explosion I
talked about how surprisingly or
somewhat surprisingly that animals were
the first to colonize or to move on land
they were but they did that before
plants did and someone brought up what I
thought was a very good question if the
animals were the first what did they eat
so I thought that that just that was one
a good question so it just divided a
whole a whole video on clarifying
exactly who was first on the land so
right here this is a picture of algae on
the coast this is kind of algal scum
right over here so this right here is
algae and just to be clear sometimes
cyanobacteria which we talked about is
the first photosynthetic organism
sometimes that's called called
blue-green algae but that's really
bacteria algae is considered to be
eukaryotic and it just doesn't have the
structures of modern plants so this is
algae right here and our best our best
estimate is that algae actually colonize
kind of coastal rocks about 1.2 billion
years ago so this is 1.2 billion years
ago G for a Giga billion years ago so if
you wanted the first thing that even
resembled or was close to plants or
animals and if you consider algae close
to a plant then this would be the winner
of who got on land first this is 1.2
billion years ago now in the last video
where I talked about animals colonizing
the land first
they weren't animals that only existed
on land they were they would have been
animals that probably spent most of
their time in the ocean collecting food
or whatever and then they would show up
on the land maybe delay eggs and if you
think about it back then the land would
have been a really good place to lay
eggs because there was there wouldn't
have been much else on the land so you'd
have been protected from pettite
predators so it might have been it might
have been slug-like creatures like this
some people talk about kind of spider
like creatures but it still would have
been at the coast and these would have
been these would have been creatures
that would have spent a lot of time in
the ocean and sometime in their land so
this is what I was referring to as kind
of animals colonizing the land before
plants and this would have happened
about five hundred and thirty million
years
go five hundred thirty five hundred
thirty million million years ago now the
first the first living organisms to
fully live on the land their whole life
is on the land those would be plant so
it depends what if you think about
things that live part of their life you
get the animals things that live the
whole life on the land then you go back
to the plants so this right here this is
what we think the first primitive plants
would have looked like and the evidence
we actually don't have fossils from
these plants themselves we have fossils
of their spores but we think that these
the earliest fossils of their spores
will show that these existed were about
475 million years ago so this is 400
metres in another color this right over
here is 475 million years ago so 1.2
billion years ago you have the algae 530
million years ago we have evidence of
things kind of oozing out of the ocean
and maybe laying their eggs or something
475 million years ago we have evidence
of what we would kind of call really
plants but the evidence is really the
the fossils of their spores and then the
first evidence of real I guess you could
call them animals that are spent their
entire life on the land the oldest
fossil we have it was discovered in
Scotland fairly recently in 2004 and it
was this is the fossil right over here
was actually discovered by a bus driver
by Mike Newman Mike Newman who was a bus
driver in Scotland and they actually
named the thing after him it's called
new mo desmos Nnamani so they got the
the new money from Mike Newman and this
fossil is 428 million years old
428 million million years old and right
now it's the oldest fossil we have of a
true land animal so if you think about
true land if you think about true plants
versus true land animals things that
spent their entire life on the land the
plants do win out if you think about
things that spend part of their time on
the land
then the animals probably won out if you
think if you view algae as plants and
the plants won out so it depends where
you want to draw the line and this this
first fossil this is this is of a
myriapod which is which just means a lot
of legs let me write over here myriapod
you probably know the word myriad myriad
means a bunch of things are you know a
huge amount so myriapod a huge amount of
a huge amount of legs and you might be
familiar with the millipedes and
centipedes those are myriapods and so
those first primitive myriapods 428
million years ago and they would have
lived off of plants and maybe other
myriapods and other slugs and whatever
other animals they might have found
might have looked might have looked
something like that so hopefully that
gives a little bit of clarification over
I'm it wasn't like you know you had a
dogs sitting on the land and they had
nothing to eat it was kind of a you know
it's it's not it's kind of a gray or and
what you define a plant or an animal and
who gets kind of the bragging rights for
being the first on the land and it
depends on really what you consider a
plant or animal and whether you know
spending part of your life on the land
whether part of spending part of your
life on the plant on the land will
actually qualify